can I open my eyes we've had these for
like a week and I hid them or mark would
never look that's painting me in a bad
light but you're right am i good can I
have my uh sour patch kids they like an
angel in the night I've done it again
with not one not two but two different
new objects for us to urine and lust
after sour patch kids go-gurt this makes
sense in a weird way it also doesn't
make sense sour patch kids is not a
flavor Sour Patch Kids is a so unless
there are sour bits inside of this
go-gurt I feel like I'm going to be
disappointed also why was this in the
produce drawer so you were lying to
yourself this whole time I'm not gonna
really do what's in here yet until I
finished my review of partay get out of
here loser all right
this video isn't about go-gurt or sour
patch kids
I'm leaving by the time you watch this
video I am out of the country I have
escaped
I have fled please don't try to find me
I had to run as far in as fast as I
could
if you find this video tell my mom well
she she she's with me I'm in Korea South
Korea specifically because I know there
are gonna be questions about that but
yes I'm going to Korea also addendum hey
I am Korean half Korean specifically
this comes with a surprise every time I
say it and I've been learning in Korean
for the better part of two years now so
I'm going to create for I'm going to
Korea for a month to solidify my
education of Korean and by the time I
come back in my month-long purgatory I
will be conversational in Korean that
doesn't mean that I'm fluid
that doesn't mean that I'm fluent it
just means that I can carry a
conversation with some general
understanding of what people are saying
and I have the confidence and the skill
set to be able to do that what does this
mean for you zoom I know I'm a
professional youtuber ami I know exactly
where my face is in frame at all times
now listen what does this mean for you
well nothing not a damn thing
because content is still going to be
coming at you hard and fast you're gonna
get it all you're gonna like it because
I've got lined up 30 days worth of
you've got watch included
you've got a man of Moodle you got the
Blair Witch Project oh yeah you've got
all of the different games that you want
to see lined up day after day after day
and in addition to that out doom there's
some special projects coming up both in
the audiovisual Department and also in
the auditory department but these
neither of these both different big
projects are the big project that's
coming out oh no
that's coming out even later than the
soon that those others are coming out
this month I've been working very hard
to make sure that everything is in order
I often joke about being a good youtuber
but in reality sometimes I fall short of
that anyway time onto the content let's
go Bros is bopping go kill them kill
them mark you must destroy all of them
you know you want to kill them all you
want the glod you want Det
you want our killer mark go the man's
yogurt with
[Laughter]
so go I haven't had go-gurt
ever because I was far too poor to
afford yogurt let alone the on-the-go
version of yogurt but sour patch kids in
their library towers have decided to put
their children inside of gogurts so the
cycle is now reversed the wheel has been
broken
instead of kids eating yogurt its Gobert
eating kids whoever is the CEO of sour
patch kids right now because there must
have been a CEO change they are geniuses
they are getting their hands in
everything they're making deals they're
making moves and I love the hustle
anyway I'm not here to appreciate the
hustle I'm here to appreciate the flavor
sensation that's sweeping the nation in
my aggression I actually opened it
relatively correctly if you've never had
that you're this is go-gurt it's not in
it alone it's not in a horrible it's in
a too but so we've got blue raspberry
and we've got red berries like those
points of his berries they have on
bushes that you're told not to eat as a
kid cuz it'll kill you I'm sorry that
just really threw me off because we
called red berry anyway so we got blue
raspberry and got red berry there are
many red berries that I know of so I'm
guessing this is all blue raspberries of
synthetic synthetic a synthetic
synthetic since synthetic flavor because
I don't want to be disappointed to some
cases bad I want to kind of buffer my
feelings against red berry because red
berry is an enigmatic flavor that who
knows what that's like all we know is
it's going to read okay first off this
is bad for the environment why not just
let it be something that kind of tears
off halfway and you or you just to a bit
open
wanna make it this out of paper why
don't gotta be plastic you're killing
Turtles
it's much more sour than I thought it
was going to be I mean you're usually
has a bit of a tang to it and and that's
what I like about yogurt is it because I
like sour things in general this is one
of those things that naturally has a fit
to it it's so weird cuz we're going down
the cavalcade of the reasons why the
cereal didn't work and we're going into
the reasons why this works in other
aspects ice cream can be sour because
it's got a little tang to it it's got a
nice nice flair to it frozen yogurt
already works yogurt in general has a
tang to it and this is accentuated by
the fact that there's now red berry it's
probably more sour than most people
would actually like I love this this
fantastic that's really good it's like
all sure there's no fattening of all the
things in life to suddenly be declared
fat-free dairy products they hey that's
what milk is okay it's basically fat and
protein and just a little bit of
carbohydrates but it's fat and it's
protein because it's meant to keep our
gaming
wejust alive every time someone takes
fat is something derived from dairy an
angel dies 16 angels were killed in the
making of this box alone yeah let me try
the blue raspberry no as far as flavor
combinations go red and blue I don't
know if it just taps into my early
millennial brain but like red and blue
is the color combination of my childhood
so what every single candy in the candy
store had a red and they had a blue and
this is really tapping into it I'm gonna
put that back in the box as a surprise
for later English teacher in the
dinosaur
pancake thesaurus Rex look at that
that's this pointing because I love blue
raspberry
I like blue raspberry almost anything I
default the blue raspberry and this is
just not as good as typical blue
raspberry stuff I don't know it's like
the sour is moving into bitterness
that's the only way that I could explain
it the punch of flavor is missing out of
the blue raspberry it's got the tang
it's got sourness but there's no flavor
behind it and especially not blue
raspberry blue raspberry has such as
this distinctive flavor because it's a
pure chemical it's not actually a flavor
derived from anything natural it's all
synthetic and therefore it should cut
through just about anything but I think
there's actually probably a chemical
reaction going on in this goat that's
creating like liquid cyanide that's I'm
inviting and I'm probably gonna die red
Maryville very good there's a distinct
difference between these and I like red
berry a lot better in case I said it in
any sort of [ __ ] way I'm leaving for
a month I'm going to Korea there are
videos prepped the whole time it's okay
hey listen here's a lullaby playing in
background isn't it nice where's my keys
let me dangle them in front of you see
that's something to be distracted by
maybe get my keys quick let's in but put
keys right here
jangle jangle hey it's gonna be okay
look at the keys hey I love you and I'll
be back I'm gonna be gone for 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 times 3 I know you can do
your multiplications 10 times 3 sleepies
so when I'm when you go sleep you're
counting one when you go sleep again you
come to you go sleep 3-0 times that's 30
big number I'll be back but in the
meantime you're gonna be very confused
cuz you're gonna go to your computer and
you're gonna go to my channel
youtube.com slash markiplier
bring that Bell you're gonna see my face
but it's not me in that day okay it's
okay though cuz I am in Korea and I can
be in two places at once with the power
of a Internet when you watch this right
now this is a message from the future
from the past to you in the future I'll
always be thinking of you I'm not dead
maybe a lot I answered that question a
bit more thoroughly now sponsor me
please whoever is in charge of sour
patch kids please get in touch with me
because I just want to talk with someone
as smart as this this is genius I don't
even know a ghost is I've never heard of
ghost I don't know if it existed before
it was sour patch kids and I don't care
because now it's amazing I don't even
care of this tastes like [ __ ] because
pre-record should taste like [ __ ] if I'm
to be perfectly honest okay so if you
don't know what pre-workout is I don't
take pre-workout because they don't
consistently workout I've seen these
results naturally will give me
you don't know what pre-workout is it's
a supplement that typically bodybuilders
but I guess most athletes could do this
as well I don't know i don't take
pre-workout myself but what it's
supposed to do is it gets so you can
lift harder did you got your show and
you can throw it so that's what free
work is also it's got some nutrients in
there that helps you with recovery and
helps you maintain you know longer
training sessions it's mostly [ __ ]
because FDA and no government agency no
regulatory body has any say over what
goes in supplements so they can put
horse snot in here and they can market
it as a excellent pre-workout and people
would still buy it and be able to eat it
there's no anything about pre-workout
and supplements in general now as far as
the benefits of pre-workout I can't
speak that but I'm sure there's a reason
that people take it so why not so in
case you didn't know it's usually in a
powdered form you mix it with water you
blend it up and then you just you
[ __ ] don't ham on those weights
it's got branched chain amino acids l
leucine isoleucine valine Astrakhan not
estrogen estrogen with an a.1 estrogen
if I die is cute so missed I think one
scoops for pansies so I'm gonna do two
scoops
I'm so glad 2019 has turned out this way
it's so worth all the disasters and
horrible things of 2019 to lead up to
this point where I'm able to eat drink
Sour Patch Kids pre-workout
[Applause]
[Music]
that's way frothy er that I thought it'd
be a VI mixed up and upon drinking this
I should turn into a raging monstrosity
that's capable of busting out reps the
likes of which I could only dream of I
think if she asked gee that's a good
residual like if flavors stuck in every
corner of my mouth it's not bad it's bad
I think it's gonna kill me that's why I
tell ghosts could you bout to be one
yeah that tastes like vomit does it take
like sour patch kids at all there's no I
mean there was a wave of sour but it
tasted like like acid
I think halfway through my brain relay
I'm not drinking someone else's straight
stomach acid like what is this man
[Music]
Oh stuff I think I do state
powdered skeletons have what were
formerly the sour patch kids that's why
it's called ghost cuz kids are dead and
I hate them I gotta leave the country